Is the fear that readers won't care
about your life stopping you from
writing online? Well, for the students
in my creative non-fiction writing
seminar, the answer is yes. They enroll
in the course thinking, who am I to
write? My life is pretty dull. And what
professional experience I've had, there
are already experts writing about it.
But that all changes after writing just
three essays. So, in this video, I'm
going to show you why you don't need to
be a real writer to start writing
creative non-fiction. how your boring
life is actually perfect writing
material and how you can use your
experience to write non-fiction that
stands apart from the naval gazing
journal entries that we see online by
providing real value to readers. And
we're going to do that by looking at an
example of a creative non-fiction essay
that all my students read at the start
of the semester. By the way, if you're
new here, my name is William. I'm an
English professor and I help non-fiction
writers write well. So, if you want to
learn more about the art and science of
expert writing, be sure to grab my free
newsletter, Writer Science. Link is down
below the like button. And so, to begin,
I think what we need to do is understand
what we mean when we talk about creative
non-fiction. So, imagine an axis that
goes from creative to non-creative and
fiction to non-fiction. So, up here in
creative fiction, you have basically
what you would expect whenever you think
of creative writing. You know, we have
literary fiction, avantgard and sci-fi.
And the goal of this kind of writing is
innovation. Like we tell stories, but
ultimately the reason that this genre
works of creative fiction is that even
though those stories are in a sense made
up fictions, they touch on something
deeper. We watch these dramas because
they tell us something more universal
about the human experience. And then
going down here to non-creative fiction.
Well, that would be genre novels. So, so
think about like those Harley Quinn
romances, uh, detective novels, young
adult fiction. On Amazon Kindle these
days, there's a lot of like romance
novels and other genre fiction that
people just buy for 99 cents and just
fly through. So, this kind of writing
really focuses on reproducing familiar
patterns that that readers are familiar
with. And then going over here to
non-creative non-fiction that is you
know think journalism academic reports
memos and instruction manuals. So the
the goal here in this kind of writing is
just plain English plain information
transfer right factual and functional.
But then moving up to creative
non-fiction. This is the sweet spot
where we're writing about non-fiction.
So, it's anchored in reality, but like
creative fiction, we are aiming beyond
the facts. We're trying to touch
something deeper, something true,
something universal that will provide
readers real value. Because the fact is
that a lot of people who write about
their experience online, we see that a
lot on Substack these days. They're not,
it's anchored in reality, but they're
not aiming beyond the facts. And so a
lot of these pieces turn into
unfortunately glorified journal entries.
And that's the reason that a lot of them
don't get read is that readers don't
perceive any value in it beyond the
facts. So, learning the art of creative
non-fiction is really about using events
from your real life as the stuff like
the raw material of something more
creative, something more transcendent,
something deeper, something true,
something universally true beyond the
particulars of the situation that you're
writing about. And so, for an example of
that, I want to show you this uh essay
which I have all the students in my
class read at the beginning of the
semester. And the practice is that
they'll read it and then they will write
a response paper to this essay because
that's the way the class proceeds is
that every class will look at one
student's piece of writing and everybody
in the class will write that person a
response paper. And so we practice that
by looking at this which I think is an
an excellent example of creative
non-fiction. It's called Learning to
Surf. It's by the writer uh David
Guestner. And in general, the piece is
about uh the author's experience moving
to a coastal town. The author has just
had a child. He's taken on a new job and
he is there on the coast learning how to
surf. At the same time, while he's out
there on the water, he's observing
pelicans. And so there are these uh
three themes which we see introduced in
the opening chapter. So like this not
chapter there are sections which are um
broken apart by these um by these waves.
So there are about five or six uh
sections but the first thing that I want
to draw your attention to is the way
that all the sections that follow all
the ideas and threads that are developed
throughout the piece they're all present
in these opening three or four
paragraphs. And so I'm going to spend uh
closer time just kind of showing you
this opening and then we'll go through
the other sections a little bit more
closely. But let's just read this
opening uh paragraph together. So it
says, "Out beyond the breaking waves,
they sit there bobbing. Two groups of
animals, aven and human, pelicans and
surfers. As they rise and fall on humps
of water, the pelicans look entirely
unperturbed, their foot long bills
pulled like blades into scabbards,
fitting like puzzle pieces into the
curves of their throats. The surfers,
mostly kids, look equally casual. A girl
lies supine on her board, looking up at
the sky, one leg crossed over the other
in an almost exaggerated posture of
relaxation. For the most part, the birds
and surfers ignore each other, rising up
and dropping down together as the ocean
heaves and then sides. So, um, you know,
as the subheading gives us a clue, you
know, this piece is really about
stability. But you could have known that
just by looking at this opening passage
because although it's merely reporting
on the facts, one thing to notice is
like the features that the author is
calling our attention to, right? Like
you might have noticed the language that
occurs throughout it. We see that the
the animals out there on the water are
unperturbed, right? The surfers also
look casual. The girl is supine on her
board, one leg crossed over the other in
an almost exaggerated posture of
relaxation and they ignore each other
rising and dropping together as the
ocean heaves and size. Now th this
image, this opening image tells you
everything that like it kind of
everything opens up out of this image.
And the fact that these features are
what the author is calling our attention
to is already giving us a sense of what
we mean by creative non-fiction. The
non-fiction is just a reporting of the
facts. But the fact that the writer is
kind of in a sense pointing the camera
at these things and using these specific
concepts to illustrate these things.
like the fact that he notes they look
casual, they're relaxed, they're
dropping, rising up and down together as
the ocean, the environment around them
heaves and then sides. So this becomes a
kind of opening metaphor for the rest of
the piece and it tells us something
about the writer. I won't spoil it yet,
but it tells you something that these
are the features that are interesting to
the writer and these are the ones that
he chooses to call our attention to.
Now, similarly, another theme that's
going to open up here is the way in
which he links us to these animals, aven
and human, pelican and surfer. And so,
right away, we see the project of this
piece. Now, this piece that we're
looking at in particular, um it it it
has a certain uh goal, which is to make
readers see he's a nature writer, so he
wants us to kind of identify with the
natural world, and that's going to come
about a lot. But um what we see at the
beginning is that he's trying to tell us
we're both animals, right? These
pelicans and surfers, they're both
they're different animals. They're
joined in the animal kingdom and they're
both responding to the environment with
this kind of uh posture of relaxation.
And right away at the beginning, I've
circled them in green. And then um just
down here as well, daughter is in green.
So these are the characters in the
piece. And this is excellent. It's like
the opening number in a play or a
musical or something where all the
characters are being introduced. Now,
we're going to see these pelicans again.
We're going to see these surfers again.
We're going to see his daughter again.
And even the ocean becomes a kind of
character. We learn that uh locals refer
to the ocean as it. So then, you know,
we drop into um a kind of dialogue here.
When he goes to the cafe, the coffee
shop, he hears the locals talking. What
did it look like this morning? Right?
The locals refer to it as it. The thing
that I want to kind of draw your
attention to in this opening is that
right away we get all the characters and
we get the the main themes. Like
everything that we have in this opening
section is going to be expanded upon and
developed in all the subsequent
sections. We don't get anything new
that's not already contained in the germ
of this opening. So that's what I love
about this opening. We get the
characters and we get all the opening
themes. Now, I've circled this uh line
here, fitting like puzzle pieces into
the curves of their throats because it's
also a way of setting up one of the
other main themes in this piece, which
is evolution. We're going to talk a lot
about evolution as the piece goes on.
And so, right away, we're given a clue
about that. This this idea of the the
their their bulls, sorry, their bills
fitting into the back of their um um how
do I say their uh the curves of their
throat like puzzle pieces, right? that
that's an image that you could associate
with evolution and you know Richard
Dawkins has in that book the the blind
watch maker. So point here is that we're
getting all these themes just um at the
opening and then as we go through this
kind of opening, right? We're we're
we're in the coffee shop, we hear people
talking and then we get our first
reference. And so this is an important
thing is like look at the way the writer
is using this quote. Look at what's h
the the the few select times the writer
pulls in outside research, pulls in
something from outside of the
non-fiction reporting. Let's think a
little bit about why and let's look at
you know h how that works. So the first
one we get here is this concept of
functions lust and it comes from um you
know this reference right here and it's
a German word and we're given the
definition of pleasure taken in what one
can do best. So the surfers are
practicing functions lust just like the
pelicans. They're they're both in their
nature and they're they're taking
pleasure in what they can do best. And
we're going to see that come up a little
bit later. But but here I just want to
kind of call attention to the select
times that the writer brings in or or
things from outside the non-fiction
reporting. Why does the writer do it and
how does the writer use that in the
development of the piece? So we'll see
functions less come up a little bit
later, but right now it's um it's enough
to just note that he uses it to describe
the obsession that um the surfers have.
And again, we see the crossover. you
know, he's trying to link them to this
idea of animals. And notice the swap
here. He says that uh the surfers, their
lives centered on being strong animals
in their obsession. And these surfers
must feel animal pleasure as they glide
and weave through the water. And then we
transition to the other character, the
pelicans. When they lift off, they have
even more impressive athletic feats. So
the pelicans are like athletes and the
surfers are like animals. So again, this
crossover really serves the writer's
purpose, which is trying to get us to
identify with nature. And we're given a
kind of introduction here. And one of
the words that you're going to see used
to describe the the pelicans is
graceful, right? We're going to see that
again and again. They're they're
symphonic. Like it's it's good to just
kind of look at the the choice words and
concepts that the writer uses to
illustrate our early understanding of
these animals, right? We see rhythm,
symphonic, graceful, they glide, effort,
glide, effort. And he thinks that
they're glorious. So, you know, we we
see there's a way in which he there's
something in the pelicans, in what he's
noticing about them that he wants to
emulate in his own life, and we don't
quite know why yet. We know that he's
just moved to this area, but we don't
quite know why he's so interested in the
grace of the pelicans, in the animal
pleasure um that the the children find
in in practicing surfing. But these are
the things that he's noticing. And then
we go into the next section, which I've
labeled here weak stability because uh
at the end there's a credit reporter. He
he's applied for a loan for a car and he
gets some bad news because he's told
that he has weak stability. Now, do we
honestly think that this is a factual
reporting? Right? Did did the person
from the credit agency actually call the
writer and say, "Sir, you have weak
stability, right?" Probably not. And and
so that is one kind of artistic license
that I think you have in this genre of
creative non-fiction. It's not exactly
necessary that everything is told. This
isn't journalism, right? you're not ma
you're not required to report on the
facts and only the facts. But if we
allow that this is a kind of um
contrivance that he's made this up, we
can think a little bit about why. And I
think what this the the purpose that
this serves like he probably did
actually receive bad news about his car
and that his credit wasn't very good.
And he was probably told something to
this effect, but he's taken poetic
license here to term it weak stability
because that phrase gives us such strong
contrast to all the strength and
stability that he's noted in the
Pelicans and in the surfers. So again, I
mean, I think I think you have artistic
license in this genre, but it should
always be to a certain purpose. And so
in this section, we're learning more
about the writer and we learn that he's
tried to maintain a relaxed attitude,
right? He wants to be relaxed and he
notices that there is they're almost in
an exaggerated posture of relaxation. He
wants that relaxation in his life, but
it's hard since he's moved to this
island. Uh his home is Cape Cod, but now
he's moved to North Carolina because he
has a new daughter, Hadley, and he was
lured. Right? Keep in mind that word
lure is, you know, what we use whenever
we're catching fish, just like the
ocean. So, we're developing the the
imagery here. There's there's still a
kind of web of the the signification,
the words that he's choosing to ex to um
express this situation is still linked
in this um kind of environment of the
ocean. And so, he's lured in just like a
fish of health insurance and a steady
paycheck. and he found that
irresistible. And so he's on the hook
now. And the move has unsettled him.
Look at all the words I've circled here
as a point of contrast to the concepts
that we saw up here. We saw relaxation,
grace, glorious, symphony. These are all
words of stability. And then in here,
we're getting all these concepts that
signal weak stability. Disorient, cry,
fall apart, shaky, unsettled. And he at
times he just wants to crawl into a cool
dang place and lie there and be still,
right? But he has bad news.
Unconditioned car right now. It's like a
kiln and he can't afford a new car
because he has weak stability. He nods
and considers the poetry of his words.
Okay, moving on to the next section
which I've labeled joy because again
it's useful to like zoom out if we can
like you know we want to look up close
but then we want to look at these entire
units. So we have this opening here you
know where we've um we're kind of
setting the scene. Then we get we we
come in here and we start talking about
weak stability. Okay. So now we see some
tension. But then up here we have joy.
This section that tells us a little bit
like joy and it mainly focuses on his
daughter. Right? So he has this new
daughter which he calls a a squirming
little ape-like animal and that uh
walking with his daughter in a
papooselike contraption on his chest.
Papoose is the sling that the Algangquin
used to use to um carry their their
children. So again, he's he's linking
this to the sheer animal pleasure. And
then the second quote comes in. So
again, all of these quotes, all the out
anything that comes in from outside the
kind of material reporting on the
situation serves a purpose. And so here
we have joy, right? Joy is the symptom
by which right conduct is measured. And
that comes from um thorough, right? So
he says, "Okay, well, if that's true,
then my conduct must be excellent
because I feel joy and that must mean
that I'm doing something right." So even
though times are hard, things are
unstable, he still feels joy when he's
there with his daughter. And so he must
be doing something right. It's not all
that is wrong in the world. So
ultimately, what this is bringing us to
is that he just needs to learn to surf,
right? There's all these uh vicissitudes
in the water and he has weak stability.
He knows he's in the right place, but he
keeps getting pummeled by the waves. And
so what he needs to do is learn to surf
just like the just like the surfers,
just like the pelicans. That's what he
needs to embibe in order to kind of um
move into this next phase of life. So
moving the attention away from his
daughter and the idea idea of joy. Now
he's looking at pelicans. And we see
some crossover between, you know, what
he was going through with his daughter
and what he notices here. the
relationship between the firstear
pelicans who are flying bellyto belly
with their shadows. It's exhilarating to
see the way they lift up and down, sink
again on the crest of the waves. Eight
more adult birds skim right through the
valley between the waves, gliding by the
surfers, sweeping upward before plopping
onto the water. And so he again, he's
looking at them and he's trying to bring
in some of their qualities. And this is
interesting. Notice how he says,
"Feeling that it's only polite to get to
know my neighbors, I begun to read about
the birds." So, notice that he he refers
to them as his new neighbors. And then
this entire the rest of this section is
just about some of the interesting
things that he learns through his
research. He's not going to educate us
like a like a Wikipedia article as
though he's an expert. Um, he he's
telling us, well, I didn't really know a
lot about them. And so, now he goes and
does some of his research. And what does
he find? He finds some interesting
features about them, right? They're
unintentional physicists. Just like the
surfers, they have this kind of grace
and and like brilliance about the way
that they navigate uh the water. They go
through their lives as near mutes. Um
they always remain silent. Oh, and then
he notices the formations that they fly
in. All of this information, all of the
the outside research, it's still couched
in the unfolding of the narrative.
Notice how all this research even at the
top line right this research is
conducted within the context of you know
his just having watched the birds right
he's with his daughter then he watches
the birds and then he goes home and he
reads about them and he starts bringing
in some information and my books confirm
what I have already noticed right and so
then Hadley his daughter and I turn home
and here they are again flying
informations at no point does the author
break from the narrative right he keeps
our focus trained on the story that's
being told but within the kind of
representational space of that story the
the details and outside research
unfolds. So that's an important feature
of non-fiction writing is we don't want
to break apart from the story and just
kind of introduce facts or quotes in a
way that is kind of orphaned from the
unfolding of the narrative. everything
takes place within the context of the
story that unfolds. And then going on to
the next section, again, I I wanted you
to note the way that he refers to them
as neighbors because I thought this was
interesting. So, take a look. This
entire thing is all about his neighbors.
Um, if you were to read through it line
by line, you would notice that it stays
focused on the neighbors. And then in
the the opening of this next section,
which I've labeled Taste of Balance, it
says, "I'm not a good watcher." Well,
that's not exactly true. I'm a pretty
good watcher. It's just that sooner or
later I need to do more than watch. So
today I am floating awkwardly on my
neighbor. So right away look at that.
You read from left to right. So all of
this is unfolding in time and you've
just gone through four paragraphs which
have you know which are about pelicans
and at the top we're introduced to you
as neighbors. And so now I am floating
awkwardly on my neighbor. with Matt, we
realized that we're back now in the
human world. We're back in the surfer
world. I don't know if this was
intentional, but it really surprised me
when I was reading it because I, you
know, I I thought we were still talking
about pelicans and now he's trying to
float like pelicans. I'm not exactly
sure. This felt quite abrupt for me and
I I just thought that was quite clever,
right? And now his his other neighbor
Matt, it was interesting. But
nevertheless, now we're in the section
called Taste of Balance, right? We've
just finished this section where we talk
about joy, right? The joy that he he
feels with his daughter and these
features of the pelicans. And now we're
in this section called Taste of Balance.
And again, we're using this language of
um you know, he's floating awkwardly.
His legs are kicking frantically like
egg egg beaters. And uh that's in
contrast to the webbed feet of the um
the pelicans which allow them to bob
effortlessly in the ocean. This is his
f, you know, his attempts at
surfing. And then he scalds himself in
the outdoor shower. There's shock when
he finds himself riding on top of one of
the very small waves. And then he's
thrown into the waves of smashed about,
but that is enough to get a taste of
balance and a taste of stability. So
again, zooming out, it it's it's helpful
to see how the story unfolds from the
opening, you know, going down to weak
stability, but then there's joy. It's
not all bad. And now he gets his first
taste of balance. And now we drop into
this evolutionary perspective, the one
that um was signaled at the beginning of
the piece when he talked about the bills
fitting into their their faces, the back
of their neck just so. And so he notes
that the the pelicans look prehistoric.
And what we'll find referenced
throughout the piece is their rituals.
And you know the their rituals of
mating, their rituals of of um all kinds
of kind of animal behaviors he refers to
as rituals. And the reason he does this,
we'll discover a little bit later, is
because he wants to use that idea of
ritual to explain where this disease in
man comes from. He says we are detached
from the rituals of evolutionary life.
Right? the the pelicans are in sync with
uh their evolutionary rituals and so
that's why they're able to go through
the the kind of rise and fall of the
waves which such grace and he can't do
that because as man he's now detached
from it. So I just wanted to note how
he's kind of setting that up, right?
We're now switching our view from the
kind of particulars of the situation to
a more expansive evolutionary
perspective and and and watch the use of
that word rituals. And uh when he wants
to get the history of the pelicans, he
notes that early uh oranthologists, you
know, people who were writing about the
species, they had quite uh choice
language to describe them. They called
them grotesque and that they had like a
quiet dignity and that they were stupid
birds. Uh they had lubrious expressions,
undemonstrative habits, and that they
were more befitting for a funeral than
any joyous display. And that even their
pearls are a lustrous white. I've
circled that because it comes up later.
But what he's noticing here is that
even, you know, in 1922 and even among
more modern writers, this is the way
that these birds are described. And
that's great. He he almost takes this
personally. It's kind of funny the way
the writer gets upset about the way that
they are um characterized as being
preposterous because that never occurred
to him. You know, here he is and he went
buy them a sandbar and he laughed as he
watched them waddle like Guliver among
the Lilipushians. Um but ugly is just
mean-spirited. So maybe they're a little
bit awkward, but like they're not ugly
because he's developed now such an
affinity with these birds. You can see
he develops kind of a grudge with those
past writers. And so again, we see this
language about rituals coming up. But he
says that compared to our own erratic
lives, the lives of pelicans appear
consistent, reliable, even ritualistic,
like they've been doing this for 30
million years. And he's he's calling our
attention to this again, not to give us
facts about the pelicans, but all of
these details occur within the context
of the story. So he says to himself,
that's the kind of animal I am. I'm
built for change. I'm built for
adaptation. So the pelicans become a
kind of mirror against which the author
is fashioning himself. And you know the
the entire even though we're learning a
lot about pelicans, the narrative itself
is about the author and his own
adaptation to this new environment. You
know he says long before we became dull
practitioners of agriculture, human
beings were nomads capable of surviving
in dozens of different environments. So
you know now and now we are beyond
ritual. So without these primal
guidelines of ritual we are left facing
a kind of uncertainty on good day that
on good days gives us a lot of options
but on bad days gives us chaos. And he
says although it's uncomfortable
building a foundation on uncertainty it
has the advantage of being consistent
with reality. So ultimately what he's
coming to is kind of like a Buddhist
understanding of you know the nature of
life like nature is like the ocean. It
is change. There is no stability. This
idea of weak stability like there is no
stability but we have to build our
foundation on that weak stability. We
can't as humans we cannot build our
foundation of um you know establishing
oursel in the world with this
understanding or expectation of
consistency because life gives us
exactly the opposite. And so he's trying
to update his model, you know,
understanding of the world. And the
pelicans are what's giving him that kind
of updated understanding. So he says
that, then this is going to come up
later. He says the best that we can do
is to not make false claims for
certainty and to try to ride as
gracefully as we can on the uncertain.
And so now we come in and we we we get
him surfing a little bit and we get some
observations of the transition from
depression to joy through small
achievements. you know, he's talking
about the depression that he feels and
he's already kind of identified um where
that comes from. And then he calls back
to this image of the girl that he saw
right at the opening, the girl who had
an almost exaggerated expression of a
relaxation, right? He remembers back to
her and now he's out there in the water
bobbing upside bobbing up and down and
he sees, you know, just with getting up
on his board holding um oh his do
thinking about his daughter getting up
holding her own bottle and he feels the
joy that these small achievements bring
and that you know maybe she in her own
way will um find her own functions lust
whether that's surfing or something
else. So his daughter becomes a way of
developing this idea that joy comes from
small achievements. And then he looks at
the pelican and he notices that the pel
this is so great. Okay, just I'm going
to back up and do this again because
this is great. So he notes that joy
comes from small achievements. And
again, this is not in the abstract. This
is given to us as he's thinking about
his daughter, right? She learns to hold
up her bottle joy and functions lust.
And then he looks up at the pelicans and
he notes that they're leaning backwards
in their posture right as they're flying
above. They're kind of leaning backwards
while they're looking down at the water.
And then he remembers that uh his friend
Matt told him that the reason he's not
surfing well is because he's been
putting too much weight his weight too
far back on the board. So just like the
pelicans, he copies their expression and
he makes a little bit of progress. He
gets up on a wave and he has a lot of
joy. He lets out a hoot and he's
laughing out loud. He's finally done it.
And so again, joy from these small
achievements and then he quits, right?
In the next section, he quits. He
introduces this new concept of
habituation. And so he's been living
there for some time now. Some time has
passed. He's kind of used to the
pelicans flying overhead. He's um given
up on the uh surfing because he notes
that, you know, on a biological level,
novelty is vital to the human
experience. But after a while, the
novelty fades into habituation and he
abruptly quits surfing because he
decides that there's kind of danger in
it. And now that he's become a father,
right, he used to fear fatherhood,
right? Earlier in the piece, he was
really fearing fatherhood, but now he's
become habituated to it. And now it's
changed his his understanding of the
world, right? He he now sees the way
disaster seems to loom around every
corner. disaster that might befall his
daughter. And so he says there's no
sense adding death by surfing to the
list. This decision is also couched in
this kind of understanding of human
nature. You know, on a biological level,
novelty is vital to the human
experience. And he uses this I he
introduces this idea of habituation here
because it's going to play out in in the
next section. Well, and so the second in
the second to last section, we see
novelty fading into intimacy. And the
reason I put these headings at the at
the start of each section is because
it's important to understand like the
function of each piece at the paragraph
level, right? Every paragraph should
have a single message, but then each of
those messages should cohhere into a
larger kind of macro pattern. And so
that's what I've done here. I've kind of
thought about what are the larger
functions of each of these sections. And
so you know here we have the last
section but just before that we have a
kind of observation of how novelty fades
into intimacy right and that the
pelicans become an image of parental
self-sacrifice.
So he draws our attention again to the
ritual of mating um the actual the we we
see that twice and of course he's going
to see part of himself in in those
rituals being an unearly father. And
that's that's setting us up for the next
section because we're going to go to
their mating grounds in just a moment.
But he reminds himself that this kind of
uh sympathy that he feels for these
birds itself has an evolutionary
purpose. Right? You might it might be
considered sentimental by some maybe
anthropo anthropomorphizing the
pelicans, right? Seeing human qualities
in them, but what he sees in the
pelicans and what many people uh before
him have seen is this image of parental
self-sacrifice. So he goes through kind
of early uh uses of pelicans in
mythology and he finds that early like
in the Bible pelicans are used as both a
symbol of parental self-sacrifice and on
a grander scale the sacrifice of Christ.
And it turns out that that's based on a
kind of misunderstanding of their
nature. He he mentions that at one point
but even later in Shakespeare the image
of parental self-sacrifice is reversed.
So in King Lear, he calls his daughter
those pelican daughters who who betrayed
him. So we get these kind of external
references and this is a kind of like
slow point in the story, but it's
setting up the next piece which really
hits everything home. And so the next
section, the final section, we get the
year culminating in a single day when
somebody from the Ottabon Society takes
him out to an island where the their
mating grounds, the mating grounds of
the pelicans. And this is significant
because if you think about it, this is
the first time in the story that the
setting has changed. Every, you know, we
begin when he's arrived in this new
village and every scene so far has taken
place there on the coast. Either he's in
the water or he's on the beach looking
at the water. And so just now for the
first time, he's leaving all of that
behind. He's being taken by somebody
from the the Ottabon Society to explore
their mating ground. So he's leaving
behind his his the familiarity, his
family and everything. and is going to
this new environment. And so they go to
four islands and he, you know, he he
calls back to those old naturalists who
called, again, he's really kind of
worked up about that. So he he, you
know, reminds us that they called them
undemonstrative and legubrious, but I'll
go with calm. In fact, while we're
anthropomorphizing, I might as well put
Buddhaike in front of calm. It's hard
not to project this on them after
experiencing the wild defensiveness of
the term colony. And so he's he's
linking them to Buddha. And I mean just
go back to this observation. The best
that we can do is not make false claims
for certainty and to try to ride as
gracefully as we can on the uncertain. I
mean that's practically a quote from
Buddha. So we see the way that early
observations are now being manifest in
this image that he gives us of Buddha.
And that image of Buddha does some other
work too because of course in Buddhism
there's this idea of you know no
beginning and no ending kind of
continuous cycles of birth and rebirth.
And so that's exactly what we get there
because he's watching these eggs hatch
and he references the hope and
precariousness, the danger and growth,
how they all go hand by hand and as a
father something that he knows well. And
then this next paragraph really hits
home the thing that he was setting up at
the beginning. Right? The idea that both
surfers, humans, and pelicans are
animals. And he says, "I'm not exactly
sure what I gain from interwining my own
life with the lives of animals, but I
enjoy it on a purely physical level.
That's that functions lust." So this
move of linking the animal world with
the human world to kind of reflect to
develop our understanding of one through
the other that is his as a writer his
functions less. And he notes that our
understanding of DNA undermines the myth
of our species uniqueness. We are
animals. And in this piece in
particular, that's the thesis. That's
what he really wants to drive home is
that we are animals and that when we
pretend that we're something better, we
become something worse. Now, of course,
not every creative non-fiction piece is
going to share this same thesis, but we
see as a natural writer, that's what he
wants us to see. And suddenly it starts
to make sense why he's he's spent so
much time using pelicans as point of
reflection for our understanding of
human experience. And we see now, you
know, this this term returns habituation
and that that is the the person who took
him out to this island must be
habituated to it. But now that they look
at some of the eggs that are hatching,
they look anything but lusterless as
those early naturalists write. And
finally, he notes that watching these
eggs hatch, you cannot think about
death. Not right now. All you can think
about is beginnings. And of course, any
idiot can say can see that it's the
beginning of something. But what we may
what may be harder to see is that it's
also the great and epic continuation. So
we get both of these time scales in this
piece. We get the local kind of
experience of up and down, birth and
death, stability and instability. But
when we zoom out and we look at the
evolutionary perspective, what we see is
a great and epic continuation. And so
writing about personal experiences this
way is really the the power of creative
non-fiction. You know, a lot of uh
writers or people who want to start
writing feel like they can't start
writing because they're not real writers
and that their lives are too boring for
compelling content. But when you think
about this story, like it's a very
straightforward story of a man learning
to surf, but he's just probed into these
experiences a little bit deeper. He's
not some Shakespeare inventing dramas.
He's just looking at the dramas of his
own life a little bit more closely and
trying to draw out something
transcendent about them. So this problem
of not having an interesting life, well,
creative non-fiction flips that. Your
ordinary experience is exactly what
others need to read about, provided that
you know how to use writing not just to
express yourself, but also to help
readers understand the world differently
and solve problems. So watch this video
next because it's going to let you in on
my writing system that'll take you from
start to finish to write and publish
your first piece of valuable content. So
be sure to go check it out.